So today is an exciting day because the papers are due,
uh,
is,
the midterm is soon,
but most of all,
because we're finishing up our talk on the mayor of engines,
uh,
questions,
comments,
cat names.
So the Merovingians remember that the reason we're studying them as is as an
example of barbarian king ship are burying states and the Post Roman world post
Roman,
um,
meaning that the Roman Empire is gone,
but the society is not completely severed.
It's connections with the Roman tradition are not severed.
This is most obvious in the church and the survival of Latin learning,
bishops,
Christianity Literacy.
Okay.
But even though we seem to be in an environment of rather primitive,
uh,
and even we could use the word loosely,
barbarian kings,
uh,
I hope that we'll see that within Gregory's narrative there is evidence of a
kind of royal administration and a certain sense of purpose.
We are entering a period in which we have to start asking what held society
together.
This becomes a question when two things start to fail.
One is the government where it's really not clear that there is a government
other than powerful people plundering less powerful people.
And the other factor is when the people themselves don't really believe that
there is any force holding their society together.
Anything that they unconsciously give deference to.
So we're all familiar with what are called now,
failed states that his policies that have an official existence but that cannot
seem to keep the most basic form of order within their borders,
whatever those borders may be.
So,
uh,
unfortunate states like Somalia or no longer,
but,
uh,
10 years ago,
Liberia,
Sierra Leone were examples of failed states.
And this is a phenomenon that has grown in the contemporary world
in the Middle Ages.
And here we're talking about the period from the collapse of Roman authority in
the West and the fifth century until I'm at least the 12th century.
There are various kinds of societies that are held together.
They are not as anarchic as Somalia,
uh,
actually,
but they are not held together by government in the sense that we understand it.
They are held together partly by informal social networks and ties,
things like kinship,
family,
private vengeance,
religion.
But by having to ask the question what holds society together,
you are already making a kind of statement about the sort of society you're
talking about.
I would say that the United States has,
for most of its history been a polity in which this kind of question didn't have
to be asked.
It's not that people loved the government or even particularly deferred to it,
but that in their everyday life,
in their everyday gestures and in their everyday assumptions,
they assumed that they were protected.
They normally did not have to go out with a weapon in order to feel that they
would not be robbed.
There are exceptional communities in the,
uh,
where that's not been true.
But generally speaking,
you could assume that,
uh,
the police or the police forces intimidated,
criminals or potential evil doers.
You would,
you know,
send your bills in by mail,
assuming that they would arrive at a government agency,
would take care of the transport of them.
You might try not to pay as much taxes as you perhaps owed,
but you wouldn't really try to just be under the radar of the government because
you would assume that you couldn't do that through would have to make some kind
of tax payment and on and on.
Educating your children of signing up for social security,
um,
you know,
being part of a community,
the mark of privilege then historically is not having to think about the ties
that holds our society together.
If you had to come up with a standard with which to measure human happiness,
that might not be such a bad one.
Now there are other forms of human happiness,
Total Independence.
The idea of,
you know,
the person who lives out somewhere on a farm and is completely self sufficient,
has all of the food that they need,
either that they catch or cultivate,
uh,
lives in some kind of wonderful climate in which the food grows on trees.
Dreams of authors of the 19th century in Europe and America,
about the South Sea Islanders.
Uh,
so we have in our imagination the idea of living a blissful life without any
particular social ties or only the most,
uh,
casual ones.
But I think we all know that usually,
um,
such
an existence when it in fact exists at all,
is an invitation for someone else to plunder it and to steal it.
Part of the reason for social ties,
his company,
part of the reason for social ties his protection.
So in asking what held barbarian societies together,
we're asking something that's more than just a banal question of medieval
sociology.
We're asking a question about the fundamental nature of a society that is,
um,
not so unsuccessful as people think.
You know,
again,
nobody wakes up in five 60 ade saying how unfortunate it is that they're alive
in the dark ages.
They didn't call it the dark ages.
They didn't think it was the dark ages.
Um,
and,
uh,
it wasn't the dark ages as I hope to show it and have Gregory of tours is a
great source because he gives a lot of very miscellaneous information.
He's perhaps a a source who likes violence though he likes violence for reasons
we were talking about last week.
He wants to show that on the one hand,
the life of human beings is terrible and full of outrage and violence,
but that it is redeemed by God's solicitude and that those people who recognize
God's power as manifested through bishops,
Saints,
the rites of the church will,
if not prosper,
always in this life,
at least receive,
uh,
a reward that is commensurate with their loyalty to God.
Gregory is a pessimist.
One of the reasons,
one of the themes that guides this work.
I was going to say one of the reasons he wrote this work,
but I don't want to kind of venture that far out.
One of the aspects that unites this work is a sense of the decline of the Franks
from the model Clovis to the fools that he feels he has to deal with.
Like she'll Parak three generations,
the generation of Clovis,
his sons,
the generation of cloves,
his grandsons,
each one worse than the one before it.
So if he,
it grudgingly acknowledged that the sons of Clovis fulfilled in some sense a
mission in accord with God's plan,
he was much more clearly hostile to this third generation of Merovingian
leaders.
Okay.
He says at one point,
um,
in a part that is not in marine to this day,
one is still amazed and astonished at the disasters which befell these people.
And I think I mentioned this little passage before,
we can only contrast how their forefathers used to behave and how they
themselves are behaving today.
So he is scolding the current generation and exalting the older ways he is
scolding them for their violence.
But what about the fact that as we emphasized Clovis was violent,
what he's really scolding them for then is not violence as such,
but violence channeled to unproductive ends.
Violence is inevitable in Gregory's world.
Violence in defense of the true faith is not only acceptable but necessary in
order to defend that.
And Gregory's interest as I hope I'll show in the true faith,
is not just a defense of Christianity as a religion,
but Christianity as the thing that holds society together.
If you asked Gregory what holds society together,
he would give some kind of answer on the order of the bishops,
the saints,
the supernatural,
the church.
And then if you said,
well,
what is the role of the king in this?
It's basically to terrorize people to make sure that,
um,
the mere threat of divine vengeance is backed up by threats of a more immediate
sort through out the history of the Franks,
although not excerpted so much.
In the addition we're using,
there are examples of people who hold god Saint Martin or the Bishop or some
other saint in contempt and who pay for it often with their lives.
So in Gregory's official presentation of events,
any defiance of God is met with a thunderbolt,
but he's not actually a fool.
I know in the dark moments of 2:00 AM reading Gregory that thought may have
crossed your mind and,
and I know that you repressed it very quickly.
Um,
and uh,
it's evil of me even to raise it,
but lest you think that he's just a credulous guy who lived in the sixth century
Aad and whatever.
He,
uh,
is perceptive and he understands that most people,
most of the time of God not withstanding need something a little more immediate
to whip them into shape.
That is to follow,
uh,
a kind of basic civil order.
And that is supposed to be the ruler.
So it's fine for the ruler to be violent and it's even okay if some people get
caught in the jaws of the state,
if we can call it that or let's say the jaws of the king who should not have
been punished.
But look at the people he's dealing with.
He's dealing with people who are violent as well as kind of silly and a
quixotic.
He has this little conversation with,
um,
a chill Parak that,
you know,
reminds one of pseudo learned people,
a bloodthirsty dictators with pseudo learning on the order of the Moammar
Qadhafi.
You know,
people,
people who,
who sort of study some stuff and decide that they're experts on it because
they're able to terrorize their population.
So I'm Jill Perry issued a circular,
this is on page one 11,
a circular to the effect that the holy trinity was to,
for not two distinct persons,
but only God,
um,
that it's unseemly for God to be called a person like a mortal flesh and blood.
He also declared that the father is the same as the son.
The Holy Spirit is the same as the father and the son.
Well,
you know,
people have died and they certainly had written huge controversial works and had
lots of councils over this issue.
This is not right.
Uh,
this nobody actually really believes this in Christianity.
This is how it appeared to the profits and patriarchs.
He said,
and this is how the law itself proclaimed him,
meaning Christ.
And he then tells Gregory,
okay,
this is the law I want you and the other members of the church to believe.
And Gregory said,
give up this false belief.
You must observe the doctrines passed onto us by other teachers of the church
who followed in the footsteps of the apostles,
the teaching furnished by Hillary,
and use CBS and the confession you yourself made at baptism.
He's got to say this.
I mean,
he is very courageous to say this to the king,
but the king,
you know,
it is like somebody,
Oh,
who is extremely powerful,
denying very basic scientific facts.
Uh,
um,
Stalin tried to impose the biological theories of Lysenko,
uh,
which basically went against
the consensus of a evolutionary biology at the time.
Um,
so this kind of pseudo learning is a feature of people who,
since they being a claimed as geniuses,
and as leaders assume that their expertise carries over into all sorts of
fields.
Well,
the king grows angry.
He says,
it's quite obvious that I regard Hillary in new Zb just as my bitterest
opponents on this issue.
Uh,
not only have Saints Hillary knew Zb has been dead for years,
but they're saints.
They're theologians.
You know,
it would be like me saying,
well,
obviously a Charlemagne and Clovis are my enemies to a statement that is
ridiculous.
And,
um,
note Gregory's response.
It would suit you better to watch out that you do not make God or his saints
angry.
And that could really serve as one of the themes of the entire work.
For,
you'd fit,
know that the father,
son and Holy Spirit are all distinct in person.
And then he goes on to the theological,
um,
uh,
justification and then the kings responses.
I'm going to find some people smarter than you are.
And Gregory says such a person will not be smarter but an idiot.
Anyone who wants to follow what you propose would be an idiot grinding his teeth
at those response.
He said no more.
And then another,
uh,
visit,
another bishop is consulted.
Uh,
so the king gives this up and then he starts writing a treatise on the alphabet
and,
and wants to add some letters and uh,
tells the teachers that the educational system needs to be modified to include
these letters.
Well,
I go into this degression to show you,
first of all,
uh,
she'll perk actually is literate.
He is actually educated.
He's at least educated enough to have half baked ideas.
Uh,
and that's more than some kings of this time and later we'll be,
he tried writing poetry as well.
He also tried to depose Gregory as Bishop,
which is in some later books.
Who are these people?
Then what is the basis of their power?
The kingship is in large measure based on inherited status.
The Mirror of Indian family had an aura of sacredness and prestige that made it
impossible to conceive of anybody not have their bloodline ruling.
Okay.
This power is partly the prestige of Clovis who is seen as really the father of
his people,
bringing them into what would become France or the land land of the Franks and
converting to Christianity.
But a lot of the prestige is what might be called Pre-christian.
The long hair.
The riding around in carts,
four wheeled carts and we've seen with the long hair is quite crucial.
Once it's cut in a humiliating manner,
the representative of the family loses some crucial kind of prestige.
Remember that choice pretended to two Queen Clo Tilda,
the scissors or the sword.
Do you want your grandchildren scalp tour?
You know,
at least to give an a,
a military haircut or a maximum monastic haircut in this context or,
or do you want them killed?
And she's so angry at this that she in fact says killed.
That shows you at least the,
uh,
um,
humiliation that is involved in this haircutting.
These kings also practice something on the order of polygamy.
They are Christians,
but they are still tribal leaders in a society in which the possession of women
in the plural is a sign of status.
Um,
one passage that describes a number of different things,
uh,
a fairly usefully,
um,
is on page 58 and this is the marriage.
And again,
it seems random when you're reading through it,
but then that's the point of the lectures is to highlight the seemingly random,
isn't it?
On page 58,
she'll Perich's wives,
she'll Parak asks for Brunhilde this other visit,
gothic queen,
kind of one of his brothers asks for the hand of her sister gals wins.
Although we already had several wives.
Okay.
So he promises the envoy,
he will put away the other wives,
he will renounce them and he will be married.
Only two gals with.
And so with these assurances,
her father sent his daughter as he had sent the first,
along with a great deal of wealth.
This is what's called a Dowery,
A payment made,
uh,
by the bride's family to the ground.
When she came to king kill parrots.
She was received with great honor and made his wife and for the time being his
love for her was considerable force.
He had brought great treasure.
Okay.
It's not a,
you know,
a,
a we both like horseback riding kind of relationship,
although they probably did,
but because of his love for Fred Gund,
who is another wife,
a low status wife,
a wife who didn't bring him much money,
but who was mesmerizing or beautiful or certainly had a hold over him because of
his love for Fred or groomed whom he had before,
a disgraceful arose to divide them gals with had already been converted to the
Catholic creed.
That is,
she had been a physical effect.
Princess raised as an area.
She's now been converted.
She complained to the king of the wrongs.
She constantly had to endure and said that he had no respect for her.
Finally,
she asked him to give her her freedom to return to her native land.
If she left the treasures that she had brought him,
which seems like a reasonable deal,
but he made a very sick skews as he mollified her with sweet words.
And in the end he had her strangled by a slave and he himself found the corpse
on the bed.
Okay.
Why didn't he just let her go?
Keeping the treasurer,
um,
humiliating.
Probably it's better to kill her.
Uh,
uh,
why didn't he do what he said he did?
He,
you know,
he's a barbarian roller.
After her death,
God revealed a great sign of his power.
A lamp burned before her tomb suspended by a cord without anyone touching it.
The cord broke and the lamp fell to the pavement.
The hard pavement gave way before it,
and the lamp as if it had landed on some kind of soft substance was buried in
the middle and not at all broken to those who saw it.
This did not happen without a great miracle.
Well,
as miracles go in,
Greg,
give tours.
This is pretty pedestrian freak accident.
The lamp breaks a Po,
the exterior breaks,
but the,
the,
the actual lamp park does not,
but it is a sign in Gregory.
And these things don't happen at random.
Uh,
in Gregory,
the king wept over the body and then after a few days took Fred a gun back again
as his wife when he did this,
his brother's attributed gals killing to his orders and toppled him from power.
Uh,
the editor points out that probably they didn't actually,
this is a little bit to pat and it may be a case of Gregory arranging the world
so that the evil get punished,
uh,
in ways that they ought to rather than in the ways that they do or don't.
But nevertheless,
the portrait is of a,
um,
polygamous king,
a king who,
uh,
accumulates treasure a king who is unscrupulous enough to kill his wife,
does not seem to hide.
It very much
is however,
um,
vengeance has taken on him both by supernatural powers and by natural forces.
So in talking about the basis of kingship,
we have blood
and then war leadership.
I have tried not to over emphasize the violence of this society,
but it is a society in which war leadership is the major,
one of two major criteria of political leadership.
The other being spiritual leadership that we're going to talk about towards the
end of the lecture,
the loyalty of the kings entourage was based on his ability to reward them with
plunder
member.
That king cloth are,
goes out to fight the Saxons,
but the Saxons actually,
uh,
give them a good deal and offered to give up a lot of their territory.
And he says to his men,
I think this is a reasonable thing,
the Saxons are pretty well armed there.
They're willing to negotiate with us.
So on pages 50,
51 but the men won't accept that they have income on this military expedition
for political reasons.
They want plunder.
And so they force him.
They threatened to kill him if he doesn't lead them into battle.
So if in certain respects we're back to the situation of Clovis.
On the one hand he seems very powerful.
On the other hand,
he seems intimidated by his followers and this is a accurate picture of the
position of rulership of this time,
the king has to reward his followers because they're not following him for
reasons of abstract political loyalty.
They're not Merovingian patriots.
They don't have a national anthem.
I don't have a flag.
They have a pledge of allegiance,
but it's a private pledge of allegiance of warrior two warrior.
He has two ways of rewarding number,
plunder or land.
He can't pay them a salary because the economy does not produce revenue in quite
this way.
It does,
but it doesn't produce enough to reward soldiers in the way they want to be.
Therefore,
a successful leader is one who leads his troops in to victory in battle.
If he doesn't expand his possessions,
if he doesn't lead them successfully,
he's going to have to start giving away lands that belonged to the king or to
the state,
if we can call it that,
and once he starts doing that,
he's going to start having a,
an erosion of his own revenue
to the weakening of his dynasty and has power.
Okay.
For the time being in the world of Gregory of tour,
the kings are wealthy.
Um,
there is a,
a,
a description of an extraordinary dowery sent with,
uh,
the princess name for beyond the Eh page assignment that Q,
um,
uh,
that you read.
And um,
um,
there was so much stuff that it took 50 wagons to carry the golden silver and
other ornaments.
The Franks offered many gifts.
I'm giving gold some silver,
many giving horses and most garments.
Yeah,
the mother of a,
the princess brought so much gold and silver and garments that when the king saw
he thought he was left with nothing.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha.
In fact,
uh,
the quantities of gold,
silver,
silks and other fine fabrics are quite impressive.
He's kings are very wealthy and they're wealthy because of plunder.
But also because of taxes.
If you read Gregory carefully,
you will see that the kings are collecting taxes.
In order to collect taxes,
you've got to have some sort of records.
You've got to know where people are.
You've got to have a kind of register of property.
I'm distinguishing taxes from plunder.
You can plunder your own people,
that is,
you can just ride around and,
and take cattle that happened to be passing by or you know,
burn people's farms or shake them down,
you know,
a threatened to cut off their ears if they don't cough up a certain amount of
money and treasure.
The problem with that is of course you start killing your own economy and even
barbarian kings recognize that.
But they do then have a kind of um,
uh,
administration.
And here again,
we have an interesting interaction of what might be called the,
um,
the practical and the superstitious,
the death of children Erickson's by dysentery described on page one oh five,
there's a serious epidemic.
The epidemic is of course,
announced by portents whoever heard of an epidemic disease that wasn't proceeded
by comments or eclipses or you know,
a heavenly phenomenon
while the kings were quarreling.
Again,
dysentery affected nearly all of Gaul high fever with vomiting,
extreme pain in the kidneys,
headaches and neck pain,
saffron colored or even green vomit.
Uh,
some people thought it was a secret poison,
blah,
blah.
Um,
it affected children.
We lost children so sweet and dear to us when we sat on our laps or carried in
our arms and north with such care.
MMM.
Joe Parex younger son became sick.
They say when they saw that the end was near,
they baptized him.
He was doing a little better when his older brother named [inaudible] Burke was
stricken by the same disease.
Now these are the children of Fredda gunned the lower status but extremely
powerful concubine,
wife,
whatever you want to call her,
and Fred again,
seeing that they were in danger of death became repentant and she says for a
long time the divine goodness has endured,
are evil doing often it has rebuked us with fevers and other afflictions and
repentance did not follow.
Look,
now we are losing our sons.
The tears of the poor,
the laments of widows and the size of orphans are killing them.
We are left without a reason for gathering up anything.
We pile up riches and do not know for whom we gathered.
Our treasury will be left without an owner full of plunder and curses where our
store houses were.
Our store houses not already overflowing with wine,
where our barn's not already full of grain were a treasury's not laden with
gold,
silver,
precious stones,
necklaces,
and the rest of the trappings of emperors.
Look,
we are losing what we held to be even more beautiful.
Now please come.
Let us burn all the unjust registers.
In other words,
let's burn the tax registers.
Let's burn the records we have of who owes what and let what was sufficient for
your father can cloth our be sufficient for us.
And then she ordered,
brought forward the registers that Marcus,
we don't know who he is,
had delivered from her cities.
She had them thrown in the fire and then turn to the king who's not eager to
have his registers burned.
Uh,
but finally he does
and they stopped the future assessments and the kids die anyway.
After this,
she'll park,
was generous to cathedrals.
BASILICAS and the poor.
He's sort of learned his lesson,
but it's very interesting,
this idea that what is killing their children is the vengeance of God.
And that the poor,
the widows,
the orphans,
the people that they have oppressed have a kind of power of vengeance by
mobilizing this supernatural force.
On the one hand,
this is a regular old story.
People when they have faced,
are faced with difficult situations,
often pray,
uh,
often promise,
make some sort of deal.
Get me out of this.
Oh Lord and I will a never do it again.
Be uh,
do something else.
Uh,
uh,
see I'll be really grateful.
And,
uh,
sometimes it appears to work and sometimes it doesn't.
But it is a perfectly understandable,
uh,
emotion.
But the belief that supernatural forces affect politics,
the belief in the political leaders themselves,
the knowledge that they are evil.
Yeah.
And that God has at least for a while permitted this evil,
uh,
is very,
very powerful and very,
very up,
uppermost in the mind of even an uneducated,
uh,
and as Gregory himself demonstrates normally thoroughly unscrupulous character
like Fred a gun.
So what makes a good ruler?
According to Gregory knock,
peacefulness since he believes the job of the ruler is to inflict fear at the
minimum and damage more likely.
At one point he describes theater bird,
uh,
one of the suds of Clovis,
one of the members of the second generation,
the closest thing he has to a good ruler.
He says,
oh,
theater Burke.
He rolled his kingdom justly respected his bishops,
was liberal to the churches,
will leave the wants of the poor and distributed many benefits with piety and
goodwill.
So he is adjust ruler and an effective one.
But after that,
all of his good qualities,
uh,
amount to treating the church wow and treating the poor well when the church is
supposed to represent.
So in the remainder of the time we should consider what is the church,
what do we mean by the church?
Any questions so far?
The church in the society is represented by bishops and monasteries.
We will be talking about monasteries next week.
The difference is that bishops rule from cities,
even if they are just little shell remanence of Roman cities,
nevertheless they,
they rule from a population center.
They are involved with ordinary people,
or at least their administrative apparatus deals with
regular life monasteries are more a retreat from regular life where monks,
as you'll read in the rule of Saint Benedict,
live in a kind of isolated community,
renouncing the world.
Now in actual practice,
there would be more similarities than differences,
particularly as these monasteries were involved with the world quite a lot.
But it is the bishops that represent
to the extent that any aspect of society does it,
of the Roman order,
a continuation of the notion that,
um,
there is a kind of educated ruler of local society.
So the bishops are members of prominent families.
They're often members of Roman prominent families.
Remember that Gregory was bishop of tour.
The great relic of tour was the Cape of Saint Martin.
His family had been bishops of tour
because they were locally prominent under the Roman empire and continued this
prominence under the mayor of engines,
not necessarily peaceful or easily.
As I said,
Kilpatrick had tried to have him deposed a,
and you've seen the episode in which they don't get along very well,
but nevertheless his family of what he calls senatorial rank,
even though there's no senate anymore,
uh,
we're locally quite a prominent,
this relic that they guard is not the only reason for their power,
but this ships as well as monks are associated with some kind of saint
protector.
And the Saint protects churches that have relics of the saints.
A relic could be a bone,
like an arm or a jaw,
or it could be a piece of clothing associated with the saint.
And the case of Saint Martin.
Saint Martin was a military figure who's the most famous act of piety was he was
stopped by a beggar while on horseback and he,
um,
he split his cloak with a sword and gave part of it too close to this,
uh,
this beggar and this relic itself,
the cloak or a capa,
uh,
was held by the Church of Saint Martin of Tours.
And indeed it is a thought that the word chapel comes from the word for cake.
That sort of a sacred space within a church where in this era relex would have
been kept.
We'll talk a lot about relics and why they are powerful.
But for now,
I do want to talk about the mobilization of sacred power because we don't have
to ask the question,
you know,
well,
did it really work?
Did this really happen?
Uh,
uh,
did,
Saint Martin really revenge himself on people who plundered lands belonging to
him?
The important thing is to realize that the conception of the saint is not merely
that of a pious respect,
but of fear of a,
a living presence.
Somebody who,
although dead is not dead in the normal understanding of the word dead,
the bishops and monks mobilize a kind of locus of sacred power.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
again,
at 2:00 AM after you were done thinking that Gregory was a fool and may have
occurred to you that the sounds a lot like polygamy does seems to multiply
deities,
it seems to multiply the sites,
the places where the sacred has an effect and shame on you for such a thought.
How can this be polygamous?
Just because there seemed to be a bunch of different people wielding sacred
power.
Um,
we don't have to deal with this.
Certainly there seem to be a lot of people,
most of them not alive wielding sacred power and it's a rather threatening kind
of power at bat.
The bishop is a religious later.
Okay.
Some of them are religious leaders in the sense of powerfully religious forces,
but most of them are more squires than preachers.
That is,
they are landowners,
patrons,
uh,
more or less generous to the poor or to the people of the area that they rule.
It's not a religion of deep introspection.
We don't have a lot of mystical thinkers in the sixth century.
We don't have a whole lot of ethical concern except for the notion of the poor
as a collection of people with the certain rights to the ear of God.
The poor does not mean exactly what it means now,
the marginal,
the people below some kind of income level,
it means basically ordinary people without any particular unusual power in
society.
In certain respects.
The church is an aspect of the power of the Kings in certain respects.
It defies the Kings,
Gregory himself and his work is full of other examples of bishops who stand up
to the ruler and remodeled straight with the ruler that is scold the ruler.
But they can't really do this by themselves.
They have to mobilize at least the potentiality of a kind of power,
uh,
that goes beyond merely the prestige of their family or the prestige of their
office.
So for example,
and again,
this is something that's not in the Murray edition.
Uh,
an example of the power of Saint Martin.
This is at a monastery,
the monastery of lot where some other relics of Saint Martin or kept a force of
hostile troops approached and prepared to cross the river,
which runs by so that they might loot the monastery of lat,
Lat tea latte.
But I think it's pronounced lot.
This is the monastery of Saint Martin cried the monks.
You Frank's must not cross over here.
Most of those who heard this were filled with the fear of God and so withdrew,
uh,
oh.
Uh,
I just thought it was a regular old monastery,
sorry,
20 of their number.
However,
who did not fear God had no respect for the blesseds saint and they climbed into
the boat and crossed the river and driven on by the devil himself.
They slaughtered the monks,
damage the monastery and stole his possessions.
They made the,
you know,
gold and silver chalices all of these properties that they had taken into
bundles and piled on their boat.
Then they pushed off into the street.
The Keel began to sway to and fro,
and they were carried round and round.
They lost their oars,
which might've saved them.
They tried to push the,
to reach the bank by pushing the butts of their spears into the bed of the
river,
but the boat split apart.
They were all pierced through by the points of their own Lance's.
They were killed by their own javelins.
Only one of them remained unheard.
A man would rebuked the others for what they were doing.
If this anyone thinks this happened by chance,
let them consider the fact that one innocent man was saved among so many who
were doing evil after their death.
The surviving monks retrieved the corpses from the bed of the river.
They buried the dead bodies and replaced their own possessions in their
monastery.
Okay.
So this is what happens to people who plunder monasteries.
On the one hand,
the story is useful for the fact that they plunder monasteries anyway.
Okay?
And without asking the question,
did their boat really sink?
Uh,
we can see a notion of the violence of society being directed to illegitimate
ends and then being punished by the church.
In terms of the question that we have been asking,
what held society together,
a lot of the answer has to be the church and its perceived mobilization of
spiritual power.
It's not the only answer,
but it is a,
an important aspect of the cohesiveness of a,
uh,
violent but not completely unstable society.
Let me give you one more example.
MMM.
Pelagius inherited the office of count in the region of Java.
J a.
V.
O.
L.
S.
A quarrel ensued between him and Bishop Parthenia,
this which this count,
uh,
insults the bishop,
abuses him,
accuses him of all sorts of crimes and seize the property of the church,
which is of course what he really wanted to do.
They both go to the king's court.
Polonius accused the bishop of being weak and a feminine.
Where are your darling boys cried?
He with whom you live in shame and debauchery.
The vengeance of God soon brought an end to these attacks.
The following year.
Polonius law says count ship,
uh,
and uh,
became a,
a terrified that Kingston Schubert wanted him killed.
Um,
and uh,
eventually he commits suicide.
I find it hard to believe that this horrible deed could have been achieved
without the help of the devil.
For the first wound was enough to kill them unless the devil came to his
assistance to give them strength to carry out his terrible plan through to the
end,
he stabbed himself twice.
His mother rushed in beside herself with grief.
Feldon,
Eh,
fainted in front of her son.
The whole family be wailed his fate.
He was buried at the monastery of core,
known but not in Christian ground.
And no mass was sung over him.
Moral of the story,
and Gregory is great at telling you the moral of the story.
It is clear that this fate befell him only because he had wronged is bishop.
Okay.
Message of the book.
Don't mess around with these bishops.
This is a world in which spiritual power is effectively mobilized to a social
cohesion.
Gregory dies and five 94.
I just want to cast and I forward because we're going to pick this story up with
the successors to the Merovingian dynasty.
The Carolingian,
Carolyn's Ian's retrospectively named for their most famous member,
Charlemagne Corollas in Latin.
The Mirror Vingean Carolingian transition is in the middle of the eighth
century.
So this dynasty had another hundred 50 years or so,
uh,
after Gregory and they continued to be involved in civil war.
Uh,
eventually there was a terrible feud between our friend Fred [inaudible] wife of
Chill Parak and Brun held,
uh,
married to CGI bird burn.
Hilde was sister of the murdered gals wind,
uh,
whom,
Fredrick and had basically gotten murdered.
Okay.
So Bryn hill tries to a venter murdered sister Souljah Burton makes war on
shelf.
Peric
yeah.
Um,
Fred gun hires assassins to kill a bird.
and,
and you've seen that to burn.
Hilde married the,
a wayward son of chill Peric named Mira Vac a mirror.
AVEC eventually commit suicide of brand.
Hilda eventually,
after these guys passed from the scene rules,
um,
and so just Frederick and she'll perk is assassinated.
Fred a gun rules in the name of her son.
And so in fact,
in the early seventh century,
in the late sixth century,
the,
the rulers are,
um,
these two powerful and feuding women,
uh,
in six 13 cloth are the second son of Fred are good and she'll perk,
captured the agent,
Green Queen Burn held and um,
had her torn apart by wild horses.
What
is happening here behind the unedifying drama of violence and feud within a
dysfunctional family?
Dysfunctional.
A word unknown in Merovingian Frankish I'm pretty convinced is that certain
regions of the Frankish realm are identified.
If you look on the last of the maps in the appendix to the Murray Edition,
you'll see reference made to two regions that don't really correspond to today.
One is our straws yet,
which is a kind of land that encompasses the Rhine regions,
Belgium,
a little bit of Holland,
northeastern France,
and new street,
which is more the heart of France,
Paris,
the Sen.
Okay.
These will become sort of two sub realms of the mirror,
Vingean,
Frankish kingdom,
and our people that we're going to be following towards the end of the course,
the Carol engines will be associated with our Straw Zia.
We turned to England for Wednesday.
If you,
um,
still have your papers and want to give them to us,
please do so and I'll see you on Wednesday.